The third example is
really an entire class of unitary operations
known as phase operations.
These are operations
represented by any matrix that takes this form
that you see right here where theta is any real number.
So this entry right here will
always be some complex number on the unit circle.
Matrices like this are always unitary, which I will leave to you to verify.
This time, the conjugate transpose won't be equal to the original matrix unless this number here happens
to be a one or a minus one,
in which case, we end up with
either the identity matrix or sigma z, which we've
already encountered.
Specifically, transposition
won't do anything to this matrix, but taking the complex
conjugate of each entry changes this entry right here
to e to the minus i theta.
These two particular operations right here are particularly important
examples of phase operations.
For the first one, we take
theta to be pi over two, and we get this matrix right here.
This is commonly called an
S operation or an S gate when we're talking about circuits, which we won't discuss in this lesson,
but that's an important
topic that's coming up soon.
The second one is this operation. It's a T operation or a T gate.
And for this one, theta
is equal to pi over four. And so when we compute the exponential, we get this value right here, which is one plus i over
the square root of two.
Here are just a few quick examples to see a couple of these
operations in action.
Here's the action of
the Hadamard operation on ket zero and ket one.
If we go through the
matrix-vector multiplication, we see that what we obtain are the plus state and the
minus state respectively.
If we perform the Hadamard operation on the plus state and the
minus state, on the other hand, we get back to ket zero and ket one.
So if we clean things up a little bit, we can see the action more clearly.
The Hadamard operation
transforms back and forth between the zero state and the plus state and between the one state
and the minus state.
Concerning these two equations right here, notice that this gives us a simple way to detect the difference between a plus state and a minus state.
As we saw earlier in the lesson, if we measure a plus
state and a minus state with respect to the
standard basis measurement,
we get a uniform random bit in both cases, which doesn't help us to
detect the difference.
But if we perform a Hadamard
operation and then we measure, we'll see a zero if the
original state was a plus state
and a one if the original
state was a minus state.
So these two states are indeed different, and they can be discriminated
perfectly by the method that I just described,
which is to first perform
a Hadamard operation and then to measure.
Going back to the example of
a qubit state we saw before that isn't particularly special, we can see what the Hadamard
operation does to the state
by converting to the forms
that you see right here and performing the multiplication.
And here is the result
which we can convert back to the Dirac notation if we wish,
and that's one way to compute
these sorts of actions.
Here's another example that illustrates that you don't always
have to convert explicitly to a matrix vector form.
You can also perform these
computations directly using the Dirac notation.
This example concerns the T operation, and here it is right
here just for reference.
This operation has this action right here on standard basis states.
And if we want to compute
the action of the T operation on a plus state, for instance, we can start by expanding the
definition of the plus state
and then use linearity
to express the result as you see right here.
We can now just plug in
these expressions up here, do just a little bit of
simplification for the second term, and we obtain the result.
If for whatever reason we'd like to apply a Hadamard
operation to the result, we can do a similar thing.
First, we substitute the expression for T acting on the plus state and we use linearity like we did before.
And now, if we substitute the
expressions we already have for the Hadamard operation
acting on ket zero and ket one,
we obtain this. And now, we can expand the
plus state and the minus state to get this expression right here,
which we can simplify just by adding, and here is the final result.
There's nothing particularly
special about this example. It's just meant to
illustrate this alternative but equivalent way of
calculating the actions
of these operations. You can use whichever
way is more convenient in the situation at hand.
One final point about
unitary operations is that compositions of unitary
operations are represented by matrix multiplication
just like in the probabilistic setting, i.e., you can compute the action of a sequence of unitary operations
by simply multiplying
the matrices together. And what you'll get is
a single unitary matrix representing the combined action